hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in letter 113
Seneca is going to set out a number of
different arguments that are intended to
go against a doctrine or idea or claim
that appears to have been regarded by
most Stoics as correct so we can say
it's part of stoic orthodoxy to some
degree he's also going to provide some
some arguments a little bit later on
about how you know the example of
earlier stoic shows that you don't have
to be so committed to something solely
because the other Stoics thinks so and
then it's okay to dissent the issue at
hand is a rather paradoxical one from
what we can tell from what Seneca tells
us and from what we can confirm in a
later text the epitome of stoic ethics
by areas didymus the Stoics at least
most of them held that the virtues are
in some respect animate creatures or in
in Senecas latin on amalia so things
that actually have a life of their own
you can say they are animate and so what
are the virtues that we're talking about
of course the Stoics regarded virtue is
being fourfold
these are the cardinal virtues of wisdom
justice temperance and courage so each
of these within a person would be a
living thing in addition to the person
him or herself being a living thing or
if you like the mind the animal the
autumn Moss as opposed to the anima the
soul being the living thing so there
would be a lot of interesting problems
and implications to this and Seneca
begins by telling us two of the
arguments that the Stoics provided for
this rather strange position so the
first argument goes like this the mind
the animal is an animate creature that
is uncontroversial since the mind makes
us animate creatures and the expression
animate creatures amalia is derived from
it from animal or from on it from sorry
from on a must in this case right the
second part is but virtue is just the
mind disposed in a certain way so you
know courage is having the mind in a
certain courageous configuration justice
likewise a certain can courageous
configuration therefore virtue is an
animal creature now that argument
doesn't look like a particularly good
one when you first think about it and
we're gonna see why in just a moment but
it was an argument apparently that was
being made here's another argument a
little bit stronger one virtue does
something but nothing can be done
without an impulse and impetus right so
without some sort of impulse no doing so
since it has an impulse and only an
animate creature has an impulse virtue
is an animate creature that's a little
bit more of a plausible argument until
we start to examine just how impulse
works and what is having the impulse so
Seneca says these are actually not good
arguments let's take a look at why so
one of the lines of argument
he makes is that what this would lead to
a multiplication of animate creatures in
each other and particularly in the human
mind he makes this in part 3 part 6 and
part 25 so in part 3 says if virtue is
an animate creature virtue itself
possesses virtue why would that be the
case why shouldn't it possess itself in
the way that the wise person does
everything by means of virtue so virtue
asks X by means of itself well that
sounds pretty plausible but then there's
a consequence in that case all the
crafts all the arts all the disciplines
are animate creatures and likewise
everything we consider and have in our
minds and so this leads to a consequence
that Seneca thinks nobody really wants
to accept namely that up here crammed in
my head I've got this entire you know
worms nest of thoughts wiggling on top
of each other each of which is its own
animate creature right so he says that
this is the case
thousands of animate creatures are Delly
dwelling within the narrow confines of
our breasts and each of us individuals
is a multitude of animate creature or
creatures or possesses such a multitude
that's a problem a little bit later he
says if we buy into this doctrine not
only will the virtues be animate
creatures but their opposing vices will
be too and and you might at that point
say well okay maybe I'll accept that but
then he goes further he says so will all
of our emotions like anger fear grief
and mistrust all opinions all thoughts
will be animate creatures he says this
is completely unacceptable right we're
not going to say that we're just a
competent of all these different animal
creatures again wiggling around inside
of ourselves maybe having their own
animate creatures inside of themselves a
little bit later in 25 he comes back to
this and he says you know I I you know I
deny that the minds actions are animate
creatures otherwise all words will be
anim
and so all lines of verse four if
prudent speeches are good and every good
as an animate creature speech is an
animate creature so that is a big
problem
so this line of argument you know which
some people might actually accept they
might be saying I'm kind of cool with
the idea that I'm just a composite of
all sorts of animate creatures and this
this big you know hole that somehow held
together by my mind I mean it just seems
to say something like that in terms of
willing right not everybody would
necessarily reject this but Seneca
thinks that the Stoics have good reason
to to reject this and so does anybody at
the time who's sort of right thinking
and doesn't want to consider themselves
to be a non unified batch of things
another argument that he gives that's
kind of interesting and I think is a bit
more metaphysically apt is that
individual animal creatures singular in
the Latin must have individual
substances and he uses the word
substantial there so he really does mean
substances in order to be an individual
animal creature you essentially have to
be a substance and our virtues
substances know they you could say our
states of or dispositions of substances
they are not substances themselves
there's no Platonism here where you know
justice is platonic form existing out
there in the intelligible world more
real than the Justice that we have
within our soul for the Stoics it goes
so far in another letter to say all the
justices are in fact material they are
corporeal because that's what the Stoics
thought thought existed so that's
another interesting argument that's
being given there and that's in sections
four and five so let's just highlight
this he says the anima creatures you're
speaking of have only one mind each
therefore it's only possible for each of
them to be one animate creature not
multiple animate creatures I myself and
both inanimate creature and a human
being but there's not two of us right
we're not we're not separate substances
myself as a human being and an animate
creature I'm the same thing I'm the same
substance which happens to be an animate
substance so he goes down he says the
two would have to be separate if they
were really different I mean the one
would have to be disjointed from the
other to constitute to anything that's
multiple in a single entity falls under
a as he says single nature or saw single
substance so we have substances and then
we have you might say modalities or or
you know ways in which that substance is
configured a third argument that he
gives is an interesting analogy to the
Hydra this is along similar lines this
is in Section eight he says
if justice is an animate creature other
than actually nine we could say they're
not many because they're connected to a
single thing by virtue of being the
parts and the components of the single
thing so we're giving our mind a shape
like that of the Hydra any one of whose
heads fights just by itself and causes
harm just by itself if you if you don't
know about the legendary Hydra and
you're thinking about GI Joe instead
which is modeled after that you've got
this this dragon-like creature and it's
got many different heads all wiggling
around you know sort of on snake little
things and they bite people and each one
seems to have a mind of its own
but Seneca is saying no it doesn't
really have a mind of its own it's just
doing what it does is part of this
substance in our own time you know given
what we know about nerve cells and
brains and things like that
a better comparison might actually be
the octopus which appears to have entire
you know something like a semi brain in
each of its appendages which can operate
independently once they're cut off but
so long as they're all part of one big
thing they're they're not in
separate according to two Seneca so he
says to give another example no one said
that the lion or the dragon and a
chimera is an animate creature these are
its parts the parts are not animate
creatures the whole is animate and the
parts if they have any animation it's
because of the whole that they're
they're part of another thing that he's
considering which goes right to this
impetus argument the impulse of virtue
is really an impulse belonging to the
mind so that that's a very interesting
thing he says why do you say that
justice is an animate creature it does
something it has some effect in the
world it generates something what is it
benefit it benefits anything that acts
and benefits has an impulse that he says
and what has an impulse and impetus to
go to the earlier argument that the
Starks are making is an animate creature
so because justice in us makes us do
good things for other people it
therefore is animate and Seneca says
well let's hold on there it's not the
justice itself that has the impulse it's
the person who is being in some way you
know configured by justice technically
speaking although he doesn't go into
this here what it would be is that the
ruling part of the human being the
hegemony cone would be configured in
such a way that it would it would lead
to these impulses of doing justice to
other people right it's not the justice
itself that makes the person do things
like the justice is some sort of like
you know person inside saying do this do
that you know a little homunculus the
justice is rather the way in which the
particular ruling part of that person is
configured same thing with courage or
temperance or wisdom so says that the
impulse actually belongs to the mind
similar you know things are going to be
argued a little bit later another one is
that the virtues actually
share in a single mind and a single body
and he's making these through sections
12 to 14 he says a single mind cannot
belong to two animate creatures right
much less a larger number so if justice
courage self-control on the other
virtues are animate creatures
how will they have a single mind
they must have minds of their own
otherwise they're not animate creatures
and the implication there is that they
don't actually have minds of their own
they don't have you know the same thing
that they're in inside of them then it
also says a plurality of animate
creatures cannot have a single body
either what is the body of justice the
mind what is the body of courage same
mind so you see a similar logic leading
in the same direction because of the
corporeality of the mind in of the
virtues for the Stoics now we get to a
really interesting argument that has to
do with how human action works according
to the Stoics so the Stoics think that
first there's what's called the
impression the fantasia in greek specky
a in in latin right there's other words
for it used as well there's some sort of
thing that comes upon us and then we
feel or think or something goes on in us
and we've got some sort of impulse
towards it like you know I see the thing
coming at me and I'm like whoa better
get out of the way right that better get
out of the way is the impulse and then
our mind either a sense to it or doesn't
assent to it it might be like oh no I I
don't need to get out of the way that's
the dentist drill it's going to get rid
of my cavity right or I could be like
yeah I need to get out of the way that's
the dodge ball and I don't want to get
hit because then I'll be off the team or
it's gonna knock my glasses off or
something like that so there's this
chain and what what Seneca is focused on
here is that last part of the chain the
ascent because the ascent is what we
what we have control over and where our
moral responsibility lies right so he
tells us that the virtues them
selves don't actually have the capacity
for a cent he says no animate creature
endowed with reason does anything unless
first it's been prompted by the
impression of some particular thing next
it's entertainment impulse finally
assent has confirmed this impulse let me
tell you what assent is it is fitting
for me to walk I walk only after I've
told myself this and have approved my
judgment it's fitting for me to sit only
then do I sit Seneca then follows up he
says this assent is not found in virtue
and he says let's think this through
imagine that we're looking at prudence
how will prudence assent to the judgment
it is fitting for me to walk that's not
within the nature of prudence that is
within the nature of the mind itself
so he says prudence looks to the thing
to the interests of the thing it belongs
to not to itself since it's incapable of
walking or sitting so prudence does not
possess a sense and what does not
possess a scent is not an animate
creature endowed with reason so at this
point you know the person could argue
well maybe it's irrational so it says if
virtue is an animate creature it's
something rational but it is not
something rational therefore it's not an
animate creature if virtue is an animate
creature and every good as virtue every
good is an animate creature right and
there you go she goes on along those
lines so because virtue doesn't cause
assent or bring about assent but maybe
it'll make a scent easier or structure
the ascent that we have it's not an
animate creature finally the last one
that he gives is quite funny and he
knows that it's funny
he knows it's as we would say ridiculous
right ridiculous means something you can
laugh that says if the virtues are
actually going to be animate creatures
then they're going to be like other
animate creatures says if justice and
courage are animate creatures are
certainly earthly every earthly animate
creature what happens to it it gets sick
and hungry and thirsty
therefore justice gets sick courage gets
hungry and
merci gets thirsty so you know this is
supposed to be a reductio ad absurdum
you're not gonna say that justice
actually gets sick you can say the
person gets sick but not justice so all
of this is leading to the point of
realizing that these virtues although
they're quite powerful and very
important they're not animal creatures
the way that the many of the other
Stoics are claiming them to be and so
here's Senecas consideration of this and
his willingness to depart from stoic
orthodoxy
you